this great big story is by IBM traffic
accidents is one of the biggest killers
in the world people are always around my
waist
[Music]
meet Comey Waldemar 'i'm a celebrated
IBM computer scientist and africa's
first master inventor we a good computer
scientist uses algorithms and techniques
to solve real-world problems the first
law is learned from the environment and
second is adapt to the context where you
live in this is downtown nairobi people
use their phone for everything the
cardig nature of nairobi usually leads
to as are these situations I was
somewhere in there we'll be having
coffee in the morning I saw the people
are always just concentrate on the phone
these ladies on the phone
the car was coming in the wrong
direction
[Music]
there was it trying to yell and shout
like I hit her I felt sad and I came
back and said can we do something to
prevent such accidents this is the smart
one the safety system for pedestrians
here's how the system works you have
more than 65 sensors in your smartphone
you know the GPS ins
soro meters motion sensor the phone
knows how fast you are typing or walking
or talking it also knows whether you're
walking in a dangerous neighborhood or a
faulty staircase one is a sensor once
the data Jaya if one is a data collector
and also fallen Nation an application
the software in the phone Komi system
analyzes the data to understand the
context calculate risk and warn the user
of danger this is just one of a hundred
patents Comey has filed for IBM in his
young career this is the only industrial
research lab in the continent we dress
problems across Africa one thing I found
a very unique in IBM is the diverse and
detailed nature of the company the
expertise and mentorship and the
environment that encourages intellectual
freedom I'm always curious
I'm always wants to understand I just
grab my coffee and sit outside and I
start thinking what would be the next
invention
[Music]
you